a school board meeting in loudoun county
virginia a brawl
breaking out and a couple of people were
arrested parents protesting the woke
school policies
but things really get heated after
officials try to shut down debate during
the meeting
as long as you marxist push your
unconstitutional agenda
on my child she will not be returning
back to mountain county schools
you're teaching children to hate others
because of their skin color
and you're forcing them to lie about
other kid's gender
and now the chair of the school board is
accusing parents of quote
dog whistle politics and says she will
continue to focus on
equity there's that word for students
not equality
but equity how do you have equity for
students that means they all have to
have the same outcome yeah that's crazy
anyway that's not a question my question
is i've never seen
uh uh kind of a cult-like thinking
spread so fast in so many different
areas of the world you have the joint
chief of staff
general mark milley defending critical
race theory so it's gotten to the
military
is this where the war is going to take
place at the school well when you
let's just think that you know uh
america
is run by local districts right the
democrats don't love that
yeah right remember we just had a big
fight yesterday in the house although
and then senate although it was 50 50.
so it wasn't that big a fight
but split right down the middle on
voting rights because the democrats want
to federalize the whole thing
yeah and but i think that a lot of times
progressives are very very
patient and they'll just get a little
put a little something over here a
little something over here and let it
spread
well this time it didn't work out and
now you have people going to school
board meetings that they've probably
never been to a school board meeting in
their life
and now they're there every night the
thing that happened here was really
unfortunate there was 255 people i think
signed up to speak they only got through
59 of them and then they cut off debate
right i think the school board would
have been better off just sitting back
and saying
have at it you know and let them get let
the air out
yeah jesse we now know uh over the past
year that the teachers unions are
corrupt
crt is intellectually corrupt and even
psychologically damaging
it feels like the time is right for an
educational tea party like a movement
i think you should leave you said that
yesterday i know i shouldn't lead
anything
and i agree with you this is one way you
could save the world this is
how you saved education this is the
right and the left black and white
uniting against the teaching of racism
and reverse racism
to our students and that's what this is
this is reverse
racism and people are galvanized and i
would say it's a new
part of the tea party joe biden himself
said america is not a racist country
kamala harris agreed so critical race
theory is teaching that we are a racist
country
so this is even too crazy for joe and
kamala and look what they're doing i
looked at the loudoun county little
handbook they are creating an anonymous
racism
snitch line they're saying you have to
confront
how white people are unconsciously
biased against black people
and they're demanding white teachers
identify their white
fragility and they don't want white
teachers to see
color they don't want they want they
don't want them to be colorblind
and that's crazy and that's what people
are upset about and it's all across the
country
in oregon uh math is racist they're
saying that black people can't succeed
in this country
that if you're white you're only
succeeding because of a white
supremacist
system that your grandparents set up
it's horrible and i'm glad people are
rising up
and snuffing it out you know geraldo
there's what
jesse's talking about there's a weird
kind of white supremacy in the con
the condescending nature of this of the
white leftists
who feel that they can they're the
person that can help the
the black downtrodden person who can't
who can't get the jobs or whatnot on
their own
but as a feat and manipulative as you
may think they are children are very
resilient
children can hear a teacher preaching
this or that
and you know i had three kids graduate
from
two graduate from spence and one left
when we moved to cleveland
but they their politics are all over the
place they're not
at all indoctrinated uh i i think that
sometimes teachers are always more
liberal
than students why are teachers so
progressive i think a lot of teachers
are
or and i'm generalizing of course i
think that teachers feel
they have a very tough job for which
they are underpaid and underappreciated
and so they they rail against the system
the kids hear it then the kids go on
they live their lives and the lessons
you take are the
people you relate to uh but my kids
turned out just fine and i'm not worried
about critical race theory
i'm not worried about uh any of these uh
these ideas
e pluribus unum that's the idea that i
tell my kids out of many
ways parents like asura nomani are
worried about the race to the bottom
as greg was talking about uh take over
the board
have at it that's what they do in
corporate america and i'm just glad my
mama is not alive
because she would have showed up at that
meeting with a tennis racket and i'd be
bailing her ass out of jail there you go
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else